insomma il primo perché c'è ovviamente
ci sono costituiti da mettere subito e
poi stanno bene io sono nato a matera ha
vissuto brave 19 anni qui il 19 maggio
ho vissuto sempre pensare ma con mi
ricordo un anno nero fuori
mia mamma che sembra pronto a fare gli
auguri mia mamma stupita che io
lavorassi quel giorno uno degli elementi
della festa che sicuramente condiziona
il bene o male la festa ed è un carro di
cartapesta e costruirlo è un privilegio
veramente dell'immenso si è credenti o
no io dico da artigiano della musica di
costruita prima bisogno e per anni a
matera la posizione di carne mattinata a
due famiglie che si alternavano che però
non avevano prodotto una bottega non
avevano uno dei collaboratori ma non
avere non erano in grado di portare
avanti per cui ci si è posti il dubbio
che la tradizione della cartapesta
potere
devo dire con queste persone allora si è
cercato di allargare la porta ad altre
persone sono sono entrati da dire cose
poi ci ho voluto provare io e un anno un
uno dei conduttori storici mi ha
coinvolto cade tinti e io felice di fan
di lui mi dice costruiscano e mantra
colto la cartapesta è un'altra cosa
allora mi sono reso conto che quella
tradizione poteva avere delle
innovazioni che in qualche maniera
volevo provare a inserire rispettando li
vedo tutti i campi della costruzione di
un cane cartapesta
la prima novità che io ho accettato di
introdurre un disegno di cultura in un
amante del rinascimento sono malato di
dichiararlo preso la sua firma tatuata
sulla chiamano il discorso della bottega
dei collaboratori mi sono reso conto
subito che un cambio in cartapesta come
il carro della bruna non può essere
costruito da solo ed è giusto che i vari
quello che voglio il napoli
abbiamo un suo risalto ok e quest'anno
stasera come fanno tutti i materiali la
fabbrica del carlo morra aveva delle
finestre coperte fino tutto punto
l'ultima finestra e la libera per cui la
nostra voglia vedere quello che succede
ha detto quello che prenderemo costruire
per non rovinarlo strega o ho messo lì
la bacca daily show e i miei
collaboratori in una squadra prima noi
stessi ci prendiamo in giro con delle
persone che sono legate alla città sono
legate alla zona in una vita non sono
privilegiate sono artiste lo fa il
meccanico falato quale l'artista degli
autobus l'altro distribuisce medicinali
un pensionato però tutti insieme abbiamo
abbiamo realizzato quello che stasera
sarà benedetto e sarà visibile
spero che qualcuno di voi voglia venire
a fare la fila chi viene qui salta la
fila grazie a me mi facevo passare
subito non c'è problema
dunque la la la una cosa che fate dalla
dal primo anno da inesperto
dopo l'assalto e sono andato in piazza
dove si riuniscono tutti gli assaltatori
per vedere i pezzi che non stati
strappati e per chiedere a gli
assaltatori che difficoltà avessero
avuto per cercare di migliorare per
introdurre nuovi nuovi metodi di
costruzione
ok uno degli elementi di quest'anno è
che il carro costruito senza neanche un
chiodo
quindi i quadri si possono sfilare con
due dita gli angioletti si incastrano
con un impero né lei né si sfilano è un
elemento che mi è venuto in mente la
notte del primo luglio allora io ci
passo le notti alla fabbrica del carro
quest'anno e che ci ho dormito la
fabbrica del carro e vi posso garantire
che sono dieci giorni che io non tocco
il letto perché su dieci notti che io
lavoro per il caro e la notte del primo
luglio del 2015 attraverso quella
immagine li osservavo le mie statue
l'incontro è il tema era l'incontro di
gesù con la samaritana ho cercato di
darle nel loro sguardo un qualcosa che
parlasse e mi sono reso conto che si lo
sguardo poteva funzionare ma mancava un
elemento mancava un elemento che poi ho
cercato di approfondire e nella statua e
il molte molte delle statue in
cartapesta non hanno le ciglia io volevo
introdurre leggi e ho provato su
dell'estate pro delle ciglia da
estetista parla tra le strappa quelle
che bisogna usare la carta
io sono riuscito a realizzare figlia in
carta quest'anno c'erano le ciglia in
carta che danno una bella espressione
danno danno quel tocco in più e sugli
angeli e saranno che perderanno la
madonna oppure l'estate gli atleti
stessi che trovano ad altezza uomo
quegli sguardi penso colpiranno molto le
persone altro elemento voglio che passi
dalla testata di materiale del
dell'assalto dello stato perché io lo
interpreto non come un atto vandalico
voglio che
la gente di matera gente di fuori veda
questa questa tradizione questa nostra
posto resta questo distruggere come
dicono gli altri
un lavoro di mesi non è una mandalay non
cercare di accaparrarsi un pezzo per
conservarlo e portarlo avanti e
regalarlo e quindi diciamo che la
possibilità di far di farti credere di
poter interagire con la stato etico una
cosa bella era non sono gli assaltatori
che prendono il pezzo ma il pezzo che si
lascia prendere da un saltatore perché è
avviato alcuni alcuni ragazzi che hanno
provato a tirare un pezzo mi ricordo ero
lì vicino lo strappo non riuscivo a
staccare una cornice hanno preso un
altra cosa quello stesso quadro preso da
un'altra persona giusta via subito
allora quest'anno ci sarà un secondo me
la la la la
il segno degli angioletti o dai dei
quadri che si faranno prendere da alcune
persone e il concetto che voglio
trasmettere fuori perché voglio che
passi dalla città di matera i materani
amano la loro festa a mano il carro non
lo distruggono
per atto vandalico o di sugano perché
vogliono rinnovare questa tradizione
vogliono a mantenerla viva
io dico una cosa che vivo nel mio lavoro
la vera ricchezza di un lavoro non sta
nel giusto compenso finale ma nella
possibilità di averlo potuto realizzare
io del mio carro
sono contento perché quel carro e sono
riuscito a realizzarlo
il caso di quest'anno a e pieno di
significato e pieno di impegno pieno di
di bellezza e spero credo che la
bellezza di del carro di quest'anno
possa possa far crescere la città possa
anche dal punto di vista culturale
appunto il server il giorno dal punto di
vista estetico dal punto di vista
artistico
i dipinti di quest'anno sono sono miei
sono tutti i miei non c'è la mano di
altri collaboratori la squadra ognuno
con i propri ruoli ha fatto il suo
lavoro
i dipinti sono i miei le finiture
sull'estate sono mie e ho cercato di
mettere dentro i 25 anni di esperienza
che ho lavorare sul carro per
rappresentare la città attraverso una
festa attraverso ma l'ho fatto di carta
fatto di carta e colla
credo che possa diventare un modo per
per far capire la ricchezza di una città
di una popolazione che ha un cuore e che
vuole trasmetterla anche agli altri
quest'anno ho la fortuna di avere qui a
matera diverse persone c'è c'è una
persona importante per me da milano che
è venuta è arrivata stamattina da milano
per vedere la l'inaugurazione del carro
quindi portare la cultura il concetto di
una costruzione di cartapesta anche al
di fuori di matera e può diventare anche
una trattiva perché vi posso garantire
che il 2 luglio ci sarà un mio cliente
proprietario di casa il bel gioioso che
viene a matera per vedere la festa per
viverlo e quest'anno addirittura vuole
vedere il carro da vicino vuol vederlo
sullo sfascio che non sarà uno spazio ma
sarà un una moltiplicazione dei pezzi la
vuol vedere da vicino del tet agrigento
gente di fuori e mi sono reso conto con
quelle poche persone che ho fatto
entrare la fabbrica del carro che non
erano di matera che rimangono
affascinati da questa nostra cultura di
questa nostra tradizione e e spero che
le mie innovazioni possono essere
portate avanti da altri quello che ho
cercato di fare non l'arco succede del
caro il mio metodo del lavoro non l'ho
mai tenuto chiuso per me i miei
collaboratori sanno tutto
tutte le varie fasi hanno partecipato
attivamente alle varie fasi e le persone
che vengono a vedere il carro che
chiedono anno da me tutte le
informazioni del caso
spero che che la festa di quest'anno
venga bene e che
qualcuno possa piangere veramente di
emozione
noi l'abbiamo già fatto stasera ripeto
se volete venire alla fabbrica del carro
vi faccio saltare la fila abbiamo un
bigliettino per come riconoscimento
ecco glielo facciamo vedere
ecco un altro elemento possono che ho
pensato giocare con le ombre da un po di
giorni a questa parte ho cominciato a
pubblicare delle dei giochi di ombre del
carro e ho creato il tema all'ombra del
carro
il carro deve essere cioè un passato da
essere segreto nessuno doveva vedere
capire come era fatto come non era fatto
mi sono reso conto che giocando con le
ombre non si svela il carro ma si fa
capire ai materani che il carro in
costruzione la gente arriva spesso e
volentieri al 23 di giugno
prima del 29 di giugno a vedere il caro
come se fosse stato già pronto in realtà
è un lavoro che dura mesi e queste
immagini anno mi sono reso conto dai dei
riscontri che avuto dalle persone hanno
avuto un forte interesse e stasera ci
sarà l'inverso non sarà all'ombra del
campo ma alla luce del carro alle 20 e
30 quando si apriranno le porte il carro
sarà spento o chi verrà vedrà
[Applauso]